ja Corona das große Thema heute nachdem
gestern die Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten
Mitte noch Kanzlerin Angela Merkel und
bald Kanzler Olaf Scholz getagt haben
mir ein schiefer ist bei uns hier im
Studio Bild politikchef Jan was war für
dich der entscheidende Punkt wenn wir
jetzt auf die Pressekonferenz von Jens
Spahn unter Lothar wieder warten das ist
ganz klar das
muss man sagen
anstaltungen abgesagt sind bzw noch im
ganz ganz kleinen Kreis durchgeführt
werden dürfen beispielsweise
Baden-Württemberg hat wusste gerade
beschlossen dass ab sofort nur noch
Veranstaltungen maximal 750 Personen
beispielsweise auch Fußballspieler
durchgeführt wenn da sind also wieder
echte Geister Spiele die wir dann
erleben wir und deswegen sind wir einig
in so etwas wie ein Retro Winter
speziell für die ungeimpften aber für
viele geimpfte auch du sagst
Großveranstaltung für viele ist auch das
Neujahrsfest Silvester eine
Großveranstaltung mit Feuerwerk Knallern
Böllern wir alle kennen aber auch das
wird dieses Jahr so nicht stattfinden
warum es wird so stattfinden wie im
vergangenen Jahr nämlich sehr sehr still
und in sehr kleinem Kreis die
ungeimpften ganz klar dürfen sich
ohnehin nicht treffen in großer Runde
das sagte ich bereits aber auch für die
geimpft die in Größe Runde feiern
wollten für die gibt es Beschränkung vor
allem dann wenn sie in Gebieten feiern
mit einer Inzidenz von über 350 es sind
auch keine Ansammlungen draußen Erlau es
wird flächendeckend du hast es gerade
angesprochen auch wieder ein Feuerwerk
und Böller Verbot geben genau es wird
also eine stille Nacht werden keine
keine feierwütige keine laute keine bei
dir auch Euphorie aufkommen sondern eine
wie wir sie letztes Jahr hatten was er
traurig das wird ein geteiltes Feiern
des Deutschland werden an Silvester denn
im Osten und auch im Süden des Landes
liegt die Inzidenz bei über 350 dort
also nur maximal 50 Personen in der neue
Westen Deutschlands dagegen ist sie bei
unter 350 dort also kann man feiern es
ist schon verrückt dass böllerverbot
geht aber bundesweit oder soll
bundesweit kommt das heißt da hat man
also egal welche Inzidenz es gibt gesagt
das geht gleich entdeckt so jetzt
schauen wir mal rein in die
Pressekonferenz wie letzte übrigens die
Jens Spahn als Gesundheitsminister gibt
zu den aktuellen Maßnahmen
reduzieren Sie Kontakte zu weitestgehend
weiteres Leid zu verhindern
es geht nicht darum
[Musik]
zu prüfen im Alltag das machen viele
Gott sei Dank ja auch auf dass dieser
ist Treffen dieser Kontakt jetzt so sein
muss es geht jetzt darum die 4. Welle
gemeinsam zu brechen die Betroffenen und
diejenigen die sich um sie kümmern die
Pflegekräfte die Ärztin und Ärzte werden
es Ihnen danken
zum zweiten Thema würde ich kurz auch
noch etwas sagen wir erleben gerade in
Deutschland wie die Impfkampagne wieder
enorm an Fahrt gewinnt alleine den
letzten zwei Tagen wurden 2 % der
deutschen gepostet haben ihre
Auffrischimpfung erhalten
erstmals gab es wieder über eine Million
Impfung an einem Tag war das letzte Mal
am 7. Juli der Fall über zwei Millionen
Impfung in zwei Tagen bekommen also
Schritt für Schritt zurück zu den Rekord
im Zahlen aus dem Frühjahr und im
Frühsommer
stand heute morgen gab es 12,2 Millionen
Auffrischimpfung in Deutschland und um
die Zahl auch noch mal einzuordnen wir
haben 55 Millionen zweifach geimpft
Erwachsene nur für diese ist ja der
Booster die Auffrischimpfung empfohlen
von diesem 55 Millionen gehen seine
erwachsenen haben also über zwölf
Millionen die Auffrischimpfung bereits
erhalten
von diesem 55000000 geimpften
Erwachsenen werden etwa 30 Millionen die
Sechsmonatsfrist
die weh als Richtschnur haben für die
Auffrischimpfung erreichen diese bis zum
Jahreswechsel auch alle zu Boostern
Ihnen eine Auffrischimpfung zu
ermöglichen ist auch möglich und unser
Ziel
übrigens auch wichtig jeder dritte über
60 jährige geimpfte ist bereits auch mit
einer Auffrischimpfung zusätzlich
geschützt
Booster Impfstoff jedenfalls ist genug
vorhanden und ab kommender Woche ist
eine ausreichende Zahl an Impfdosen auch
für das gestern gesteckte Ziel und 30
Millionen Impfungen zu erreichen quasi
schon ausgeliefert an die Impfungen
stellen
oder Scholz hat gestern der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz deutlich
gemacht dass die 30000000 Impfungen
gezählt werden sollen ab dem 18.11 der
letzten Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz als
es die Beschlüsse zur Auffrischimpfung
gab
seit diesem 18.11 wurden bereits zehn
Millionen Menschen geimpft wenn jetzt
alle Impfdosen genutzt werden die bis
einschließlich Anfang kommender Woche
ausgeliefert sind sind diese 30
Millionen Impfdosen schon an die
Impfungen stellen ausgeliefert zehn
Millionen sind bereits geimpft zehn
Millionen sind schon ausgeliefert
10000000 werden nächste Woche
ausgeliefert sodass jedenfalls von den
Lieferung der Impfdosen her dieses Ziel
dann nächste Woche schon erreicht werden
kann wichtig ist jetzt dass wir impfen
und es werden ja Woche für Woche bis zum
Jahresende auch weitere Impfdosen folgen
all diese
Impfdosen die ausgeliefert werden auch
zu verhelfen das wäre ein großer Erfolg
und es wäre das Ergebnis einer großen
Kraftanstrengung
mein danke daher allen Ärzten und Ärzten
ein Helferin und Helfern vor Ort die mit
viel Flexibilität die Struktur in dafür
wieder auf und ausbauen die Menschen
überzeugen und auch Überstunden viele
Überstunden leisten mein Dank gilt den
Impfstoff Herstellern die unsere Booster
Kampagne auch durch zusätzliche
Lieferungen
vorgezogene Lieferung insbesondere
möglich machen und mein Dank gilt auch
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
Ministerium bei der Bundeswehr den
Großhändlern und den Apothekern die
diese Kampagne logistisch
generalstabsmäßig organisieren unmöglich
machen durch unsere gemeinsame
Kraftanstrengung ist es gelungen in
kürzester Zeit die Impfkampagne wieder
zum Leben zu erwecken
zu werden wir auf die Zahl will ich noch
nennen von Mitte November bis Mitte
Dezember in diesen vier Wochen nach
aktueller Planung 18 Millionen Dosen bei
iontec und fast 25 Millionen Booster
Dose moderner Andi empfunden stellen
ausliefern mit all diesen Zahlen die sie
auch auf unserer Homepage finden will
ich eines deutlich machen das Erreichen
der gesteckten im Ziele scheitert
jedenfalls nicht am Impfstoff es ist für
die Ziele der nächsten 4 Wochen genug
Booster Impfstoff vorhanden
wenn wir all diese Impfdosen auf
verenden dann machten wir uns selbst das
größte Weihnachtsgeschenk denn trotz
oder auch eher wegen der neuen Virus
Variante bleibt impfen und Boostern das
beste Mittel gegen diese Pandemie
deswegen machen sie mit lassen sie sich
impfen schützen Sie sich und Ihre Lieben
so können wir diese vierte Welle recht
Infektion nicht mehr so gut erfasst
werden können weil er bohre und
Gesundheitsämter einfach nicht mehr
hinterherkommen mit testen und der
Bearbeitung von Meldungen es ist also
viel zu früh um mir eine Trendumkehr
auszulesen geschweige denn auf schärfere
Maßnahmen zu verzichten im Gegenteil
im Moment gibt es in Deutschland
geschätzt und
926 000 aktive Fälle das heißt etwas
mehr als 1%
der gesamten Bevölkerung ist zur Zeit
infiziert und wir gehen von einer unter
Erfassung von etwa Faktor 2 bis 3 aus
und
4.800 covid Patienten liegen aktuell auf
Intensivstation und die Belastung wird
in den nächsten Wochen ja zunehmen durch
die weitere nachlaufende hohe Zahl an
neuen Patienten die auf Intensivstation
kommen unweigerlich
der Warteschlange leider auf die
Todesfälle deutlich an dem Robert
Koch-Institut werden einzeln Tagen schon
um die 400 Todesfelde
und in diese Notlage in ein Platz jetzt
noch die neue Variante Omikron
wir können onikon noch nicht genau
einschätzen aber klar ist das Omikron in
Deutschland angekommen ist und nach
allem was wir mit stand heute wissen
könnte Omikron auch noch ansteckender
sein und auch geimpfte und Genesende
leichter infizieren das RKI beobachtet
on me, türlich intensiv zusammen mit
vielen Kollegen im Ausland und im Inland
und sobald neue Erkenntnisse kommen
werden wir dir natürlich auch
informieren
wir sollten uns alle darauf einstellen
Nikon in noch kürzerer Zeit zu noch mehr
Fällen führen könnte als Delta und das
in einer Situation in der das
Gesundheitssystem bereits an vielen
Stellen überlastet ist deshalb müssen
alle gestern entschiedenen Maßnahmen auf
Flächen deckend umgesetzt werden um
Infektionen durch Delta und Omicron zu
verhindern und um die Fallzahlen
herunter zu bringen dazu gehören aller
erster Linie die Reduktion von Kontakten
wir haben keine Zeit zu verlieren keinen
einzigen Tag nur wenn wir die Fallzahlen
herunter bringen können wie die Kliniken
entlasten in vielen Krankenhäusern ist
die medizinische Versorgung jetzt
bereits eingeschränkt und ich möchte
noch einmal klarmachen was das bedeuten
kann erstens für die covid Patienten die
zum Teil schon verlegt werden müssen und
die Verlegung sind eine enorme Belastung
und können die Heilungschancen
beeinträchtigen zweitens für alle
anderen wenn die Kliniken am Limit sind
wirklich dazu alle erst auf die
vermeintlich leichten eingefärbt
ich sage bewusst vermeintlich dennoch
eine Hüft OP ist in der Regel eher
medizinisch indiziert und wenn sie nicht
stattfinden kann verlängert das eben
auch das Leid der Betroffenen
etwas später wenn die Engpässe dann aber
auch bei komplexeren und schwerwiegenden
Eingriffen bemerkbar z.b. bei
Krebspatienten darüber habe ich auch vor
ein paar Tagen mit dem
Vorstandsvorsitzenden des Deutschen
Krebsforschungszentrum Professor Baumann
gesprochen um eine Krebserkrankung heile
zu können muss sie rechtzeitig erkannt
werden die moderne Krebsmedizin ist sehr
komplex sie wird über einen längeren
Zeitraum mit verschiedenen Methoden
durchgeführt
z.b. Röntgen Diagnostik Probeentnahme
Operation verschiedene Therapien
wenn ich die Diagnose verzögert oder die
Behandlung nicht optimal durchgeführt
wird sind die Heilungschancen natürlich
geringer wenn du Wäsche kein
intensivbett zur Verfügung steht kann
auch nicht operiert werden schon jetzt
finden laut Taskforce Krebs und Corona
mindestens 5% weniger Tumoroperation
Stadt es gibt internationale Auswertung
die zeigen wie sich das Sterberisiko bei
einigen Krebsarten erhöht wenn Sie eine
Operation nur um vier Wochen verzögert
das kann einer internationalen
Übersichtsarbeit pro-1000
Brustkrebspatientinnen z.b. zu mehr als
zehn also zu zehn mehr Todesfällen für
also allein bei 1000 Brustkrebspatienten
gipfelt aber oft erst viele Monate oder
später zum Tod das bedeutet dass eine
Benachteiligung von Krebspatienten wenn
dieser akuten Pandemie eben auch leicht
übersehen werden kann
also jede und jeder von uns könnte
plötzlich betroffen sein jede und jeder
von uns kann und muss dazu beitragen
Infektion zu verhindern überall im
privaten Bereich im beruflichen erreicht
in der Schule im Altenheim deshalb noch
mal wirklich der ganz klarabellas nicht
impfen achten Sie darauf dass sie im
Schutz vollständig ist und lassen sie
sich eine Auffrischungsimpfung geben und
bitte reduzieren Sie Ihre Kontakte auf
ein Minimum halten sich im Alltag über
alandia H + L Regeln also Abstand halten
Hygieneregeln Alltags mal chilligen
machst medizinischen Masken tragen oder
ffp2 Masken tragen Lüften auch bei 3G
und 2G Veranstaltung die Maske bleibt
bitte auf
wir brauchen eine hohe Impfquote und
eine niedrige Inzidenz um uns selbst und
die Einrichtung des Gesundheitswesens
vor covid-19 zu schützen und bitte wenn
Sie bereits krank sind oder wenn es ihr
nicht gut geht oder wenn dir etwas
entdecken das in Sorge bereitet suchen
Sie bitte auch in der Pandemie ihre
Ärztin Ihren Arzt nehmen Sie vor allem
auch
Früherkennungsuntersuchung war und ich
bin sehr sehr dankbar dafür dass sich
viele Menschen in unserem Land so
verantwortungsbewusst Verhalten und
damit sich selber und ihre Mitmenschen
schützen oder dass sie bis zur
Erschöpfung daran arbeiten die Situation
zu bewältigen in Kliniken in Arztpraxen
in Laboren im Öffentlichen
Gesundheitsdienst und an diversen
anderen Stellen wie auch im
Robert-Koch-Institut
vielen Dank Alina bekommt zu ihren
Fragen ich würde gerne mit den Farben
die speziell das Thema dieser
Pressekonferenz beginnen sollte Treffen
mit diesem fahren beginnen mir sollte es
darüber hinaus weitere Fragen geben
setzen wir die ans Ende geben Sie mir
dazu einfach einen kurzen Hinweis ich
beginne im Saal mit Herrn Rinke
wieso weil insbesondere natürlich die in
den geben Zweifel gar nicht merken dass
sie infizierte sind sich möglicherweise
dann auch nicht testen lassen nicht
entdeckte werden was ist im Moment
schwieriger macht sind 2 Facetten zwei
Gesichtspunkte des eine die Situation in
den Laboren wenn es um die PCR Test
umgeht die jedenfalls sind zum einen
sehr stark am Limit übrigens nicht weil
die Testkits oder Ausrüstung nicht da
wäre sondern weil auch dort natürlich
das begrenzende Momentum Personal und
personalverfügbarkeit ist wir haben
jetzt wieder Sophie PCR-Test in jeder
Woche wie auch sonst in den höchst
Phasen der Pandemie mit gleichzeitig
einem sehr sehr hohen positiv Anteil
also der and ein hoher Zahl der Testung
in den PCR Labor ist positiv so hoch wie
selten in den letzten 18 Monaten und das
deutet darauf hin dass es eine unter
Erfassung gibt und zum zweiten ist die
Situation in den Gesundheitsämter Eine
an vielen Stellen insbesondere in den
Landkreisen in den Städten mit sehr
hohem infektions geschehen wo die
Meldungen dann nicht immer Tag gleich
auch in diesem System erfasst werden
erfasst werden können weil
möglicherweise anderes gerade noch
dringlicher ist und das sehen wir ja an
den Nachmeldungen die wir haben
auch beim Robert-Koch-Institut des das
dann in dem Moment wo möglicherweise
dann die Inzidenz singen Tonstück
Entlastung eintritt diese Nachmeldung
dann auch erfolgen und im Nachhinein die
Zahlen ja dann noch erhöhen was kann man
am besten dagegen tun die
Infektionszahlen senken das Beste was
wir tun können damit wir ein gutes
Lagebild wieder haben können miteinander
ist schlicht und ergreifend
Infektionszahlen runterbringen diese
Welle brechen so dass alle auch in ihrem
Alltag im Gesundheitswesen die Dinge die
anstehen gut bewältigen können und dann
kann ihm jeder von uns mithelfen
eine andere Möglichkeit wäre dass Leute
natürlich ein Meeting in den
Infektionszahlen andere Möglichkeit die
Gesundheitsämter wieder stärker mit
Personal auszustatten auch das hatten
wir ja in der zweiten Welle ist das eine
Maßnahme die dringend angegangen werden
müsste oder sehen Sie da gar keine
Lösungsmöglichkeit natürliche
wird und soll und muss auch das Personal
verstärkt werden ich meine Bundeswehr
steht wieder auch mit Unterstützung mit
den helfenden Händen das ja auch
richtigerweise heißt und so ja auch
empfunden wird den Gesundheitsämtern zu
Seite wir tun das zum Teil mit Programm
des Bundes in den Einrichtungen die
Behörden vor Ort ziehen das Personal im
Gesundheitsamt zusammen aber eines
bleibt eben auch war in Regionen mit
Inzidenzen von
1509 Infektion pro 100.000 den letzten 7
Tagen ist das eben waren auch eine
Größenordnung
die dann auch mit zusätzlichem Personal
kurzfristig jedenfalls kaum noch
aufzufangen dann beginnen die
Gesundheitsämter ist ja auch eine
Empfehlung des RKI eine sinnvolle auch
bei der Kontaktperson Nachverfolgung vor
allem sich auf die Bereiche zu
konzentrieren wo es um vulnerabel Person
geht und Pflegeeinrichtungen z.b. oder
um größere Veranstaltungen also es gibt
ja auch Empfehlung und Maßnahmen auch
schon seit längerem wie in einer solchen
auch belastenden überlasteten
Situationen in einem Gesundheitsamt dann
Kontaktperson nachverfolgen ist Schäden
soll denn aller Regel auch dann passiert
aber das sind eben Größenordnung die wir
regional haben in Deutschland
da geht's vor allem darum diese Zahlen
runterzubringen
[Musik]
Minister Spahn in der ersten und zweiten
Corona Welle waren ja vereinigen die
Pflegeheime besonders hart betroffen
vor dem Hintergrund des nachlassenden
Impfschutzes jetzt wie gut sehen Sie die
Pflegeheime jetzt in der 4. Welle
geschützt und
wo sind sie die Verantwortung dafür dass
es jetzt doch auch immer wieder zu mehr
zu tödlichen Ausbrüchen in Pflegeheimen
kommt
also zuerst einmal haben wir ja sehr
bewusst schon im August vor allem war
zwischen Bund und Ländern die auf frisch
Kampagne auch in Pflegeeinrichtungen zu
beginnen viele Länder leider nicht alle
aber viele haben auch unmittelbar im
August begonnen mit mobilen Teams dann
wieder in die Einrichtungen auch zu
gehen das impfangebot zu machen stand
heute aus dem was uns die Länder
zurückmelden ist in nahezu allen
Pflegeeinrichtung dieses Angebot auch
gemacht worden und viele der dort Lee
Drohne ohne haben es auch angenommen und
sich zusätzlich zu schützen ist schon
mein erster sehr sehr
wichtiger. Und das zweite ist das
regelmäßige testen auch von geimpften
genesen im Personal und Besucherinnen
und Besuchern um den Eintrag in die
Einrichtung leben soweit es geht er zu
reduzieren zu minimieren auch als
zusätzlichen Schutz bei sozusagen das
ist ja neben den Landesverordnung die es
gegeben hat mittlerweile auch Bundes
gesetzlich geregelt und das kann ich nur
begrüßen
und sie dazu ergänzen die
Nachfrage
Ansicht nach auch zur Aufgabe des Pflege
beauftragten sich ein Bild über die Lage
in den Pflegeheimen zu machen und z.b.
über den stand des Boostern
aus meiner Sicht und meiner Wahrnehmung
macht sich der pflegebeauftragte täglich
ein Bild über die Lage in den
Einrichtung auch durch persönliche zum
ein Durchzug seine persönliche Gespräche
Gesprächsrunden in dieser Zeit natürlich
vor allem digital aber eben auch durch
seine tägliche Arbeit
dann nehme ich eine digitale Frage dazu
gutes Kollegen Reuter aus dem
ARD-Hauptstadtstudio zur allgemeinen
Impfpflicht bzw nehme ich gleich zwei
zusammen die erste halten Sie eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht auf für Menschen
unter 18 Jahren für sinnvoll und wenn ja
ab welchem Alter und der Kollege Jordans
von LP fragt wie soll die geplante
Impfpflicht effektiv durchgesetzt werden
geht das ohne ein zentrales Register
aller Personen Deutschland und versetzte
mit Vermerk zum Impfstatus
der allgemeine Impfpflicht immer bei 2G
Lockdown für ungeimpfte Kontakt
Beschränkung die Frage wie wir diesen
Unterschied den geimpft und nicht
geimpft sein macht auch tatsächlich
durch Regeln zum Ausdruck bringen sehr
sehr klar ich bin auch in der aus und
Ansprache sehr sehr klar dürfte wenige
bundespolitische aktive geben die sich
so vielen Diskussionsrunden gestellt
haben auch mit Menschen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen und sie zu
überzeugen aber auch um sie zu verstehen
insofern bin ich in dem Ziel sehr sehr
klar
aber die Frage wie das oben und
durchgesetzt wird und für wen das ist
tatsächlich eine Frage die ich bitte an
diejenigen zu richten die den
Gesetzentwurf erarbeiten
[Musik]
unter 18
das ist am Ende an diejenigen zu richten
die entsprechenden einem Gesetzentwurf
arbeiten meine Wahrnehmung ist das eine
verpflichtende Impfung für unter 18
jährige die
Debatte er
mit zusätzlichen
Emotionen Aspekten naturgemäß noch
versieht
gucke nicht so trivial aber ich habe
einfach nur die Bitte an diejenigen die
die sich dann damit befassen dass sie
wirklich alle diese Pros und Cons die
Abwägungen
moralischen ethischen die
gesundheitlichen eben treffen und ich
glaube da da muss das Land noch sehr
viel diskutieren das ist ja nichts Neues
also es gibt ja schon ab und an den
anderen Ländern Impfpflicht das ist ja
nun kein kein neues Phänomen darüber gab
es schon vor vielen Jahrzehnten
Diskussion da ist viel gelernt aber wie
gesagt aus meiner Sicht muss man das
alles abwägen und ich wünsche mir dass
dort eine fundierte Diskussion
stattfindet und dann auch Ebene wirklich
informierte Entscheidung im Parlament
denn wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe soll es ja eine Gewissensfrage sein
was ich auch sowieso mal nicht ich
wundere mich sowieso immer über die
Fraktion Zwänge bei bei Abstimmung auf
jeden Fall ist bei ihm Pflicht der
Gewissensfrage ist wichtig da müssen
sich die Parlamentarier gut informieren
und auseinandersetzt und dann kommt das
richtige Ergebnis raus denn eins ist
klar Sophie von der live Pressekonferenz
von Lothar Wieler und auch der letzte
Auftritt von Jens Spahn und dabei war
unser Reporter Peter Thiede der noch
Probleme hatte und uns nicht richtig
hören kann ich das Zeichen richtig deute
oder kannst du uns hören peter
du bist ganz schön laut ist alles gut
okay kein Eindruck die letzte PK von
Jens Spahn
also entspannt war hörbar bemüht die
nicht als der Gesundheitsminister
abzutreten der zum zweiten Mal die
Impfkampagne versaut hat er war
sichtlich bemüht darum klarzustellen es
ist genügend Impfstoff darum bis zum
Jahresende die 30 Millionen Menschen wie
von bald Kanzler Olaf Scholz versprochen
durch zu impfen oder zu Boostern und vor
allem ein kleiner Kracher weiß noch
dabei Jens Spahn hat klargestellt ich
habe beim bei der Impfpflicht mein
Versprechen gegeben dass es keine geben
wird und das wird auch mein
Abstimmungsverhalten Deutschen Bundestag
beeinflussen es das heißt der noch
amtierende geschäftsführende deutsche
Gesundheitsminister ist gegen die
Impfpflicht die kommen soll die die
nächste Regierung machen will
Peter das war jetzt die letzte
Pressekonferenz von Jens Spahn in diesem
Rahmen auch als amtierender
Gesundheitsminister um Hardware Ahnung
er hat so versucht doch ein Fazit zu
ziehen und die Situation zumindest etwas
stärker zu beschönigen nehme auch gesagt
hat wie viel Impfstoff eigentlich jetzt
auf dem Weg ist wie hat das ganze auf
dich gewirkt geht jetzt sparen jetzt als
jemand der quasi Essen Karriere
zerbrochen ist an der Corona Krise oder
glaubst du dass er noch mal wiederkommt
also wir müssen mal gucken wie
entspannen gestartet ist als
Gesundheitsminister Erde dass das Haus
damals politisch aufgestellt da gab's
noch gar keine Corona Krise das Haus war
politisch aufgestellt und zugeschnitten
auf ihn und auch seine Karriere dass Sie
entspannt aus dem Gesundheitsministerium
er ist ja wirklich Gesundheitspolitiker
auch gewesen vorher besser von hier aus
durchstarten kann eventuell sogar in
Richtung Kanzlerschaft dann kam Corona
dann kam alle Schwierigkeiten die alle
Minister die jede Regierung damit gehabt
haben und dann scheiterte auch hier
einsparen eigentlich permanent vor vor
sich hin die gesamte Bundesregierung
Arbeit Gesundheitsminister war da mit
der Kanzlerin vorneweg und mit 16
Ministerpräsidenten dann noch im
Schlepptau da ist ganz viel an ihm
kleben geblieben ganz vieles
schiefgelaufen jetzt hat er sich bemüht
zumindest klarzumachen dass das spiel
das gerade einige Bundesländer spielen
nämlich für ihre gescheiterten
Impfkampagne oder stockenden
Impfkampagnen jetzt auch wieder den
Bundesgesundheitsminister verantwortlich
zu machen das wollte er nicht mehr mit
Spinat lagesche Leute ich habe genug
Impfstoff eingekaufte wenn heute nicht
genug im Stoff in Rosenheim oder in
Frankfurt am Main ist dann haben die
Bundesländer und die Kommunen halt vor 4
Wochen zu wenig das ist das eine das
andere ist das natürlich seine Karriere
erstens mit koronarer abging und dass er
dann diverse falsche Entscheidung auch
parteipolitisch getroffen hat also dass
sie sich hinter Armin Laschet eingereiht
hat dass er zum Team am Armin Laschet
wurde aus dem Andernach ausgefallen ist
dass er quasi zu den gescheiterten
gehört hat er wird auch nicht
Fraktionschef werden nach allem was man
hört auch nicht in dem halben Jahr wenn
der wiedergewählt wird also dann sieht's
erstmal danach aus dass er jemand
abgestürzt ist das hier entspannen
jemand ist der das auf sich beruhen
lässt das glauben wir beide nicht an du
nicht ich nicht also ich nehme an dass
hier ein Span irgendwann ein Comeback
versuchen machen wird dass es sich in
der Partei wieder hocharbeiten wird und
in der Fraktion und dass wir in zwei bis
zweieinhalb Jahren einer starken die
entspannen sind eher so wieder probieren
wird
ja ist das jetzt ein bisschen was was er
dann der neuen Regierung zu schiebt so
nach dem Motto ich habe ja eingekauft
ihr müsst es jetzt impfen bzw dafür
versucht dafür sorgen dass es an den
Mann bzw die Frau kommt
dafür wäre am Ende des Jahres nicht
genug Impfstoff da gewesen aber bin
heute im Stoff fehlt in Rosenheim oder
in Frankfurt am Main oder in Lindow in
Brandenburg wo wir die Meldung kriegen
dann liegt das daran dass woanders zu
viel zu wenig bewusst bestellt worden
ist und dass die Impfzentren wie in
Thüringen z.b. nicht auf sind bei
gehalten worden sind sondern erstmal
geschlossen worden sind da gibt es in
die Wählerliste Versagen in den Kommunen
in die wieder das Versagen in den
Ländern und es gibt auch Versagen beim
Bund aber im Schlange dass es nicht gern
Spanien Spanisch für andere Sachen
verantwortlich aber dafür nicht Peter
geht der Täter danke für die Anordnungen
ja noch mal einmal kurz zurück
vielleicht mit einem positiven Ausblick
zum Schluss dann was Lothar Wieler er ja
gesagt hat der Präsident des
Robert-Koch-Instituts ist das die Zahlen
wieder sehr stark nach oben gehen was
das Impfen angeht jetzt sparen hat es
auch gesagt erstmals wieder über eine
Millionen Impfungen Pro Tage in den
vergangenen zwei Tagen insgesamt zwei
Millionen Impfung also der ganze Druck
der GE macht wird scheint auf jeden Fall
Wirkung zu zeigen also es gibt eine
große inspirate das haben wir im
Frühjahr ja auch gesehen wenn das ganze
erste Halbjahr in diesem Jahr ein ich
immer darüber berichtet und auch die
Frage stellt es wollen sich so fänden
viele Menschen impfen lassen wieso ist
eigentlich nicht genügend Impfstoff da
das dürfen wir ja nicht vergessen wo wir
eigentlich eher kommen dann hat über den
Sommer als auch die Inzidenz Zahlen
Infektionszahlen runter ging einfach
diese Impfbereitschaft nachgelassen bzw
ganz ganz viele Menschen waren natürlich
schon GmbH sehen wir sehr sehr viele
boosterimpfung ich habe ein Punkt ist
aber am Ende auch noch mal wichtig
herauszunehmen Jens Spahn hat schon
versucht auch heute den schwarzen Peter
noch einmal woanders hin zu schieben und
zwar haben wir in den letzten Wochen
viele viele Schlangen vor Impfzentren
gesehen lange Schlangen und wir wissen
dass dort eben nicht genügend Impfstoff
war Jan span hat immer gesagt es gibt
genügend genügend aber irgendwas ist
auch in der Logistik wieder nicht
richtig gelaufen und jetzt versucht man
krampfhaft auch die Apotheker dazu zu
bewegen dass in Apotheken beispielsweise
geben für die Impfzentren werden
holterdiepolter wie der die Vorbereitung
auf diese Phase auf diesen Herbst Winter
lieber schlecht und das ist natürlich
etwas was Jens Spahn nicht im Griff
hatte und im einfach zu sagen jetzt
sollen die Apotheker impfen das mag sich
schön anhören die Apotheke ehrlich
gesagt die bedanken sich nicht die
Verband Spitze aber die Apotheker vor
Ort die fahren sich was sollen wir
eigentlich noch alles tun also da ist
schon sehr sehr viel Chaos auch zur Zeit
da ist sehr viel ad-hoc Maßnahmen und
die große Frage ist wem ist das auch
anzuhängen und da hat Jens Spahn heute
versucht den schwarzen Peter
abzuschieben hat gesagt es gibt doch
genügend im Shop es wird auch nächste
Woche genug ausgeliefert aber nicht
Vorbereitung dafür wäre für impf denen
eigentlich die lagen auch in seinem
Zuständigkeitsbereich und das hat er
versonnen rechtzeitig auf die Rampe also
die 30 Millionen sollen erreicht werden
können interessanterweise auch indem man
jetzt einfach das Datum früher wirds
aber wann man mit diesem 30 Millionen
Versuch gestartet hat